Transcriber: Rasha Nasser
المدقّق: Anwar Dafa-Alla
(موسيقى)
أهلاً بكم في مؤتمر TEDx،
أنا أوبي، عمري 8 سنوات، في الصف الثاني.
أحب القراءة وكل شيء جديد.
من ثم أكبر وأكون رائد فضاء واكتشف الفضاء.
رائد الفضاء يجب أن يكون رياضي، لأن الفضاء
معدوم الجاذبية، والدم لا يصل لأطراف الجسم.
لذلك أنا رياضي وألعب رياضات مختلفة، أكثر
رياضة أحبها هي الشيش (المبارزه) صراحةً،
لأن بدلة المتدرب كبدلة رائد الفضاء.
(غير مسموع)
لأن بدلته تشبه بدلة رائد الفضاء.
يجب على رائد الفضاء أن يكون رياضي،
لأن في الفضاء، الدم لا يصل إلى أطراف الجسم
ولذلك أنا رياضي وألعب رياضات مختلفة.
أكثر رياضة أحبها صراحة هي مبارزة السلاح،
لأن بدلته تشبه بدلة رائد الفضاء.
من المهم جداً أن رائد الفضاء يكون مثقف،
ولديه معلومات مختلفة.
أحاول دائماً أن أتعلم وأطوّر نفسي.
الفضاء كبير وفيه مجرات كثيرة،
منهم مجرة درب التبانة،
التي تتواجد بها المجموعة الشمسية.
تتكون المجموعة الشمسية من نجم الشمس، وثمان
كواكب. منهم كوكب الأرض الذي نعيش عليه.
كوكب المريخ الذي يقع بجانب كوكب الأرض،
وهو أكثر كوكب يشابه الأرض.
دعوني أتكلم قليلاً عن المريخ،
زرت مركز العلوم وقد أخذونا في رحلة للمريخ
إن سطح المريخ يشابه سطح الأرض، لكن التربة
بها الكثير من الحديد لذلك لونه أحمر.
على الرغم من وجود آثار لمياه متجمدة، الجو
حار جداً في النهار، وبارد جداً في الليل.
لأنه لا يوجد غلاف جوي كالأرض.
وإن مازلنا نتعامل مع الأرض بشكل سيء،
سنضطر في المستقبل أن نعيش على كوكب آخر.
ماذا تعتقدون الكوكب الأنسب؟ أعتقد المريخ،
لأن مثل ماقلنا هو أكثر كوكب مشابه للأرض.
لأن كما ذكرنا هو أكثر كوكب مشابه للأرض.
إذاً، كيف يمكنني العيش على المريخ؟
يجب أن نحمي الإنسان من تقلبات الحرارة.
ونقوم بعمل تحليل للمياه، بحيث نعزل
غاز الأوكسجين، لكي نستطيع ان نتنفس.
لكي نستطيع ان نتنفس.
ونعمل سلل زراعية ومن ثم مزرعة سمكية،
إضافة لاحتياجاتنا الأساسية في الحياة.
سكن وغذاء وأوكسجين.
ليستطيع العيش على المريخ بأمان.
قرأت أن 60% من الماء الموجودة على الأرض،
مصدرها اصطدام النيازك.
وفي الفضاء الكثير من النيازك،
بالتالي ممكن وجود حياة وماء على كواكب أخرى
أرغب عندما أكبر أن أكتشف الكواكب المختلفة،
الممكن تواجد عليها حياة،
أعلم أن عدة تحديات ستقف في وجهي،
ولكني واثق اني سأتغلب عليها،
لأنني أرغب أن أكون إنسان متميز،
يعمل على تغيير في العالم.
(تصفيق)
(موسيقى)